ces partis mettez en place les filles on
démarre avec delphine delphine d'abord
attention c'est parti ici combien blanc
si jamais il ya deux balles attention
c'est parti
et vas-y d'attention attention ça me
fait très peur celle ci attendait c'est
bien mais alors je vous dis pour les
twittos vous pouvez jouer avec nous et
je vous le dis ce soir j'offre une télé
hd avec la marque au carré rouge pour la
même marque
quand on est content au foot c'est qu'il
ya voilà merci au rendez vous sur le
compte twitter tpb pas participé avec le
nom du chroniqueur ou moi si vous pensez
que c'est moi qui va gagner selon vous
celui qui a la bonne réponse
on rapporte cette magnifique télé hd
sachez je ne sais pas si vous pouvez
vraiment parié sur moi
sachez que j'ai je reviens d'une
blessure au poignet je ne peux pas trop
taper
donc voilà donc je vous le dis mais on
verra ce qu'on peut faire merci non mais
voilà que nathalie marquay d'abord pas
les 1 pourquoi voilà pourquoi qui
parient sur moi en me chagrine c'est bon
badie matière alors bien sûr delphine
vous n'avez pas été calculés delphine
pas calculé attention ça va ils vont en
avoir une deuxième super vin et d'avoir
un deuxième mois
c'est pas mal jaccottet il faut tirer la
et robin sauget pareil que pour
l'instant personne n'a été calculé la
machine deuxième est il ya quelqu'un ne
sait pas dire non non mais on a les
deuxièmes balles n'ont pour l'instant
personne n'a été calculé je le rappelle
allez c'est parti mon nom a alors j'ai
rien dit mais les championnes
alors là
c'est l'esprit est nu et foulard
souverain non c'est pas calculer mais
attention c'est pas mal c'est un beau
geste
narbo caire a dit c'est la bonne celle
là ces quelques et comment
c'est au gardien où tu vois assez marqué
la télé ça va très mal
41 ok d'accord très garantir à tous ont
déjà démarré pour ensemble le tenant du
titre i merci avant la mali regarde tout
cas quelle classe vous êtes magnifiques
alley répartie 26 zaza à me serrer la
vis c'est pas très beau cegedim a dit
avec 41 km heure c'est ça 45e allez on
passe maintenant aux autres candidats à
ce débat je rappelle que ni glané comme
très fort au tennis valérie barbier aux
autres djs matgé smac du jazz mc
attention de mal j'attends
les doigts ces appareils se mettre sans
tu danses et 133 ses calculs et amis
chefs en français
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi a dépeint comme un des
favoris du tour ont bafoué
attention voilà cinquante âmes et donc
on ne savait pas exactement soit 33
alouettes jeudi malades très louche le
sort de ça on va refaire cible le toit
n'est pas dans la cible
mais non je vous le dis pour l'instant
c'est 92 sekkat ali vient me voir faire
92e c'est fini
ils attaquent au dessus benjamin as tu
un budget énorme et je dois la vérité
que la méthode c'est parti non mais
aussi et c'est ça compte pas cesser ces
gens tour il a l'a confirmé à l'automne
il a tapé là la deuxième il a tapé le
ciel belge iba maintien mais attention
c'est parti à dire au tchad pour la
cravate rouge aujourd'hui on est en
direct
c'est pas mal barak à jérusalem est a
été dur attention et ça n'a pas tout
mais c'est pas mal merci bockel qui
doivent s je suis membre ou l'éveil de
savourer les gens tout va être dur à
battre
non non non alors attention la deuxième
attention attention
[Applaudissements]
nikolas nikos
il est où attention pourtant ces gens
tous qui ne s'est pas jouée en plus quoi
ce jeu c'est n'importe quoi
pire des cas ouais c'est souvent la
finale nicolas pernikoff tu sois prêt de
raquettes yoplait merci nicolas
non non vous plaît on est on est coach
une raquette 9 merci surtout été
utilisée passe elle la remercie
alors c'est parti nicolas pernikoff en
deux points comme hier nicolas pernikoff
toujours tina lys genre je pense que
l'on a fait alors on te pour gagner en
moyenne chacun d'eux peut mener loin
c'est parti j'ai très peur vous allez
affronter malte entre autres prévient à
jouer il a déjà une pression elle est
pas allé pas été bien parti mais mais
mais non mentionnés comme patron
[Rires]
s'en prendre aux tripes et très haut la
colla résimont ferro avec japex donne
encore quelques instants pour parier sur
twitter qui va gagner vadim niko t'as
fou devient fou et merci
[Applaudissements]